in this video you're gonna learn how to
write recursive formulas we're going to
talk about arithmetic sequences and
geometric sequences and even the famous
Fibonacci sequence so let's jump right
into this video and I'll show you how to
work with these so the first one example
one here we've got three seven eleven
fifteen nineteen dot dot so what's the
pattern can you see the pattern how are
we getting to the to the next term well
if you said that we're adding four each
time you're absolutely right and so what
you do when you write a recursive
formula is you do something like this
you tell the person you know what's the
first term that you're starting with so
a sub one that's the value of the first
term which is three and then what you do
is you give them a formula to find the
next term you know the very next term
like that so what we're gonna do is
really use this notation a sub n minus 1
sub means like subscript a little bit
below the line like a submarine below
the water right and what we're doing is
we're taking that previous term and
we're adding four and this is for when n
is greater than or equal to the second
term third term fourth term like that so
for example if we wanted to find this
term which is one two three four five
six and equals six right we want to find
the value of that term that a sub six is
the value of that term if you put six in
for n you've got the value of a sub six
is a sub six minus one which is a sub
five which is this guy right plus four
more so nineteen plus four takes you to
twenty-three and so on but after you get
used to doing these formulas for a while
you'll just realize hmm when I see that
a sub n minus 1 that means just to go
one term back you know one term before
ad four and repeat so if I want a sub
seven I go to a sub six which is C seven
minus 1 a sub six the one before plus
four more and I get 27 and you keep
going like that so this is different
than an explicit formula where you can
just put in a hundred and it takes you
to the hundredth term these are
recursive formulas which are good for
computers and you can write a little
program and it'll keep you know taking
that previous term and repeating so
let's look at example number two what's
the pattern how are they getting to the
next term in this sequence can you see
what are they doing to get to the next
one next one next one okay well if you
said multiplying by two you're
absolutely right
the first term a sub one is five right
and then if we want to write a formula
to get to the value of the a sub n term
you just take the a sub n minus one term
the one before and then you multiply by
two and that's for when n is greater
than or equal to the second term you
know so this wouldn't work if you know
you were at the first term because we
really don't know what the zeroth term
is right so that's the idea so you just
take the previous term that's what this
a sub n minus one represents and then
you tell the person how do you get to
the next term oh you just multiply by
two okay so 160 and so on okay the third
example they're giving us an explicit
formula they're saying you know if you
want to find the hundred term you put in
a hundred that's going to be three
hundred and seven but we want to write a
recursive formula so what often times
students will do is just put one in okay
n equals one so that gives you three
times one is three plus seven is 10 and
then let's maybe put two and that would
be three times two is six plus 7 is 13
let's put three in and that gives us 16
and that gives us 19 and dot dot dot so
now you can see the pattern it looks
like we're adding 3 which makes sense
because see how this is like a line like
y equals 3x plus 7 you know you're the
slope is 3 it's increasing by 3 but if
you want you can write out a few terms a
lot of students like to do that method
and then a sub 1 is the value of the
first term which is 10 and then what we
want is a formula to find the next term
in the sequence you take the previous
term a sub N minus 1 and you add 3 and
then this is just for when n is greater
than let you some teachers don't really
worry about having you write this but
I'm just showing you that in case your
teacher does so that's that one now for
example for this formula also is an
explicit formula and it takes you right
to you know whatever term you want so if
you want a hundred you put in a hundred
but before I get to these next two
examples I just wanted to mention that
if you're preparing for the AC T or the
new SAT the math sections I've got two
video courses to really help you boost
your score on those math sections of
those two important tests so you can
check out those I've got the description
in below you can check that out or the
links on my about page I've got links to
those video courses they're really
in-depth to go through 39 concepts with
the SAT one and 65 concepts with the
act1 going through teaching and then
exam
polls and practice problems so it's
really helpful a lot of students have
benefited from them and I'm sure you
will too check out the free previews to
see if it's something that you're
interested in and look into getting
those courses if you're getting ready to
take those tests but to go back to this
problem let's just write out a few of
the terms so if I put one in 1 minus 1
is 0 1/2 to the 0 power is 1 times 50 is
50 so our first term is 50 if we put 2
in 2 minus 1 is 1 1/2 to the first power
is 1/2 times 50 is 25 and you can see
we're off and running now it looks like
we're multiplying by 1/2 each time now
if you're already familiar with the
explicit formula you can see this is
your ratio so that's what we're
multiplying by and this is your first
term a sub 1 but just to show you in
case you get stuck you can always put in
a few terms starting with N equals 1 to
find the pattern but now what you can
see here is what we're doing is we're
taking that previous term and we're
multiplying by 1/2 and that's for when n
is greater than or equal to 2 okay so
the last example this is a famous
sequence it's the Fibonacci sequence
you've probably heard about this before
or maybe maybe learned about it earlier
in your math classes but see if you can
see the pattern like how are we getting
from you know these terms to the next
term can you see the pattern well what's
happening here is if you can see it is
that we're adding 1 and 1 together to
get 2 we're adding 1 and 2 together to
get 3 we're adding 2 and 3 together get
5 basically what we're doing is we're
adding the two previous terms together
to get the next term so what I'm going
to do for this one is I'm going to say
that a sub 1 is equal to 1 a sub 2 is
equal to 1 a sub n is equal to a sub n
minus 2 plus a sub n minus 1 and this is
for when n is greater than equal to 3
meaning the third term and Beyond right
so they're giving us the first two terms
C 1 and 1 if we want to find the third
term we go to the 3 minus 2 which is the
a sub one term and then the 3 minus 1
which is the a sub 2 'the term and we
add those together and we get 2 if you
want to find the a sub 4th term 4 minus
2 is 2 so we go back to the second term
before minus 1 is 3 we go back to the
third term we add those together and we
get
three and it continues like that but
after you do this a while you kind of
just look at the a sub n minus 2 and
just say to yourself hmm that just means
that I go to terms back and a sub n
minus 1 just means that I go just one
term back and I add those together and
that's how I'm getting the next term in
the sequence so I hope this helped you
understand how to write recursive
formulas you know a lot better check out
the more math videos that I have on my
Mario's math tutoring YouTube channel I
have hundreds and hundreds of videos to
help you boost your score in your math
class you make learning math a lot less
stressful and you know just help you
understand better overall subscribe to
the channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon